my name is Deirdre Guan and I just
founded the center for humans and
machines at the Max Planck Institute for
human development in Burley
the discipline of artificial
intelligence which is where I started my
study is an engineering discipline it
has the goal of building intelligent
machines so the idea is you look at
other intelligent behavior in the world
like human intelligence or animal
intelligence and then you try to mimic
that by engineering clever algorithms
having algorithms that learn on their
own and so on but your goal is always to
engineer a particular behavior that you
have in mind before the discipline of
machine behavior is the other side of
this coin once the machines have been
engineered and deployed how do you then
observe them in the real world and how
they interact with each other with
humans individual humans as well as
groups of humans so machine behavior is
a discipline of the behavioral sciences
and one should be able to study machine
behavior without understanding
necessarily how those machines are built
a machine could be designed to achieve
one goal but then once you deploy it
start doing other things they may be
because we cannot anticipate all of the
effects of this algorithm on the news or
on misinformation online or what have
you
and I think it's a behavioral scientists
have a lot to offer
to help us understand these entities
especially now that they are very much
permeating our world we carry algorithm
to pay our algorithms with us with our
cell phones they serve us news they
recommend music and products to us they
even suggest things for us to say to our
friends and so on so I think it's
imperative to bring in the behavioral
sciences so our change in behavior is
really an invitation to people from
other disciplines outside of computer
science to help us understand the things
that we are building
ten years from now it would be amazing
if we had some kind of broad theory of
different kinds of behaviors that
machines can exhibit we have a fairly
sophisticated theory of human behavior
we understand human decision-making even
errors when humans can be rational or
irrational what kind of mistakes they
make and so on but we don't have a
similar theory of machines it would be
nice if we could have a kind of
systematic way of saying there are three
types of autonomous vehicle behavior or
there are five types of recommender
system behavior it doesn't matter how
these systems learn how they're
engineered but they somehow exhibit
these kind of classes or types of
behavior so we're kind of in a stage
where we're building a broader theory of
all of this and nothing is the lacking